well can ice cream ever be healthy well
I hope so one brand is attracting more
ice cream lovers with a promise of low
calories and less guilt Time magazine
named halo top one of the best
inventions of the year over the summer
it became the best-selling pint of ice
cream in the country beating big names
like Ben & Jerry's and haagen-dazs the
first halo top scoop shop opened last
month and more plan Jamie yuccas visited
the CEO to learn about his recipe for
success let's try this for Justin
Wolverton this was even better than
being a kid in a candy store
the halo top ice-cream CEO was inside an
LA mall previewing his company's first
offering of soft-serve flavors surreal
because just a few years ago Wolverton
was a litigator at a big-name LA law
firm and hating his career everybody
thinks it's gonna be Perry Mason or like
for me a John Grisham novel and then you
get there and it's just a paperwork the
size of your torso you just decide to
jump off the cliff and take a risk this
is the ice cream machine that I started
with prompted by a pop-up ad Wolverton
bought this $20 machine back in 2011 his
homemade concoction with all natural
ingredients sparked an idea and it was
this kind of Eureka moment where it
tasted extremely good even though it
didn't have any sugar it was rich in
protein it was all natural so I was like
hey you know what here is my escape from
law you really thought in that moment
yeah at the time Wolverton owed nearly
three hundred and fifty thousand dollars
in student loans he found a partner Doug
fountain another disgruntled lawyer
willing to go deep in debt to make ice
cream it hit stores in 2012 but didn't
sell so how did you sleep at night I
slept rest
Leslie we always said I think on our
worst day at halo top and there were
there were some dark days in the early
years it still beat practicing law
pretty good targeting Millennials they
turn to social media
sending pints to YouTube influencers are
amazing but the key selling point became
about calories an entire pint has as
many as a single serving of other ice
creams I just don't know how they do it
280 calories for its entire pint it
ignited a cult-like following online
sales skyrocketed 17 million hard pack
pints in 2016 under the lid it reads
stop when you hit the bottom and
guilt-free zone
keep digging but author and dietitian
Samantha Heller says the slogans aren't
healthy for those struggling with
portion control when the ice cream
company can tell you eat the whole thing
it's encouraging bulk eating and binge
eating and that is something we're
actively trying to control in this
country but the bottom line is ice cream
is meant to tickle certain receptors
that make it almost impossible to just
be like well there's a bite and I'm
gonna put it back in but it was
Wolverton zone health problems that led
him to create a product sweetened with
stevia and erythritol a sugar alcohol my
buddy doesn't do well on sugar when you
have a hypoglycemic episode you just
turn white you look like a zombie and
you're shaking and you're sweating my
rollercoaster is a little bit more
severe than most people the company is
pushing to keep up with demand churning
out about six hundred and fifty thousand
pints a day
despite the large-scale operation they
don't own this Factory preferring to
rent Wolverton works mainly from home
near his chief clean-up officer Molly
Baer but staying small is helping him
think big I don't see any reason why
halo top can't be global
just like other ice creams are global it
could be the number one selling ice
cream in the world is that your dream
that is my dream
that is my dream yes a dream for him and
the best bite of reality for ice cream
lovers who never want just one taste for
CBS this morning
Jamie yuccas Los Angeles beyond I know
you haven't had
it appears to be guilt-free almost right
it's really cool that they have those
calories printed right on the label
there and you can see people in the
supermarket hours looking and saying oh
this one's only 250 done I'm sold
Alton caramel salted caramel